i'm i am human optimization and
optimized to to be what though to just
be happy
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
sorry we're late we uh we're we were
recording another episode and yeah look
i got the context i thought it was
fascinating i love the idea of like
your digital media company being
acquired and then you have to do a a
podcast with the guy who acquired it
who no longer works there or no longer
ceo it's fascinating
well he told a story that was i think
good because i think most people don't
want to hear necessarily from oh you're
the ceo of some marketing companies a
public company it's not the sexiest
story but he he just got in a crazy
snowmobile accident and broke like every
bone in his body
and was sort of like lying there on a
mountain for an hour thinking i might
die or you know maybe hopefully his cell
phone had like one bar and he was able
to call the police and get get a
firefighter to come save him um
so he told that story and i was like
okay this is good this is good content
then everything i'm happy with how this
turned out
wow that's that is fascinating
yeah it was good he was like it was like
a movie we were like you know brian this
is like a movie you know like
billionaire tech guy almost dies quits
and starts meditating and yeah he became
like a philanthropist afterwards he
reevaluated his life while he was lying
there that sort of thing um all right
sam you want to do a quick intro no you
do it you do it i like i've enjoyed you
uh doing it lately okay i'll give the um
i'll give the like the brief context of
this okay so rob
um i don't know if you know this but
your your show on mtv there's a there's
a kind of a meme about it on reddit do
you ever go to reddit
i do not okay so do you know of reddit
it's like a
popular kind of website or whatever of
course so me and sam both watch the the
show the challenge on mtv and um and the
challenge has been around for like 15
years it's kind of like our you know i'm
not even a guilty pleasure frankly i'm
not guilty about it i i feel great about
it it's a great choice this is great
this is great and so museum both watched
the challenge and we're probably the
only kind of like tech investor dude bro
it's
my wife my wife watches it yeah sam
hides behind his wife i love it i i'm
i'm i'm not afraid to say it i came out
the clouds i said i love the challenge
so
on on reddit there's this big separator
about the challenge and the running joke
is that mtv plays 23 hours of uh
of
ridiculous uh ridiculousness and then
one hour of the challenge
on wednesdays and so because your show
is your show is always on tv i don't
know if you know this but it's kind of
like constantly on mtv and so there's a
running joke that that's
that's all the channel is basically is
ridiculousness um
i don't know if you know about that or
if you have any thoughts but i wanted to
start there
well i mean yeah i mean it's 60 of the
total programming yeah is it really yeah
and it's it's fascinating because it's
like
you know as i
have evolved the program and my
relationship with the network and
ultimately sort of the business that i
have with the network it evolved into
creating more content and airing more
shows and so they began to air more
shows and the ratings went up higher and
higher so then now people are watching
it in blocks of you know two and three
hours at a time
so it you know in linear cable as a
whole kind of faded to appointment
television
and you had hero content that pushed up
to the forward on almost all the
networks
and i just happened to be lucky you know
what i mean of like finding that sort of
resurgence but i was also because i
control and own the
the
the production i have negotiated on the
unit economics of the show and what the
network needed as the
uh cable advertising world was evolving
so i i was able to
control it at a higher level than
traditional talent which took me from
getting 30 episode orders to 168 episode
orders which then eventually became 500
episode orders right it's a
hey
for example athletes like floyd
mayweather right starts off as a boxer
but then the promotion the production
company basically takes all the
economics and he's out here the talent
the one that's drawn in all the viewers
but didn't own that piece and then over
time now he owns it all because he he
kind of like got screwed for a few years
or you know sort of wisened up and said
oh i need to own more of this stack in
order for me to like benefit in the way
that for the value i'm bringing were you
did you get it from day one or did it
take some time for you to figure that
part out look i think you guys know the
complexity of making a successful
business right so at the at the end of
the day there's arbitrage for talent and
different aspects of business and it
relates to entertainment but the ability
to actually monetize it create value and
then in my case sell it for a
significant amount of money is
extraordinarily difficult unless you
really understand business at a really
high level so it's it's way beyond
i've you know i started my first company
at 18 years old i went through basically
years and years of
of making millions and losing millions
through ventures where i ultimately
created a system
uh to to grow into being a great
entrepreneur and then i capitalized on
uh this unfair advantage that i had in
the entertainment space to be able to
look at the opportunity and maximize it
both from a talent perspective
and create a business that i was able to
have acquired
um through that platform you know what i
mean it's i think it's more rare than it
is common for an athlete to have that
mindset yeah and let me give a
background here and this is what i'm
about to say is with no research it's
just as a fan so i don't you don't know
this but i i still skate so i've been a
fan of yours forever and so here we i i
have here look
here here it is can you see that there's
my tray flip talking about a full tray
flip right here fully caught yeah yeah
totally crazy
look at that
i can still i still have it in me a
little bit oh my camera will come back
in a second but so you um
you you started skating very young and i
think you were sponsored
by alien workshop when you were like 13
14 15 something like that right
well to give you more context like i got
sponsored it at
11 years old but i
i connected with the group and and when
they founded the alien workshop and i
turned pro for it when i was 16.
and you uh but now i think you you own
alien workshop right or your part owner
no i acquired it for four million
dollars and then i gave it back to the
original foundation that was free and
clear on top of buying a bunker in ohio
so they could run the company out of it
and gave that to them free and clear
that was the worst mistake i've ever
done in my life
was
um look i you know i i did it more they
were acquired by burton
and i i every advisor around me was like
this company does not make money it has
terrible margins like it burns cash like
this is a terrible investment i didn't
care i didn't understand business well
enough i just wanted it for the story
the hometown kid
buys back you know the alien workshop
that he sat in the room and helped
choose the name and create the brand
when he was 16 years old and finds great
success and comes back and acquires the
business and when i i acquired it i felt
like i acquired a hornet's nest and i i
learned so much about the operational
side of business and culture and and the
dynamics of
um what i'd consider a a
a toxic culture
and i just realized that that my passion
was to create build and and create an
roi and irr
for the stuff that i created and that's
that doesn't align with skateboarding
very much right like they're really like
misery loves company let's all be broke
let's all barely survive let's all like
keep your artists
everything starving artist syndrome and
i i literally
like was on another call and was like
man i don't even want to be on it i
don't want to put another bit of my
energy in here and i'm like you want to
know what the real hero story will be
i'm going to give back the original
founders who built the company and sold
it i'm going to just give the entire
thing back to them and that's what i did
so
we have to talk about that in a second
that's crazy to me uh not a bad way but
it's crazy and so you're you're a skater
you know i used to watch you in a lot of
trans world videos as a kid and a bunch
of other stuff and then you were
early-ish at i think very early at dc
shoes before dc shoes was even named dc
right
um that ended up becoming a pretty
monster success um and so you've seen a
bunch of stuff then you started some of
the early shows which crushed it and
then now you're telling you're sitting
here talking about ridiculousness and
the way that you're describing things
i'm like
it's just the evolution is crazy right
from skateboarder to like talking about
how you own 60 of the programming on mtv
and so i wanted to give like context
there because it's it's amazing and it's
inspirational but at this point you've
got your hands and everything it seems
like you've got you do you dabble you do
a bunch of stuff if i remember correctly
years ago you had like a food truck is
that right
um
i might have wrote an episode around a
food truck but it was probably fake a
fantasy factory
you had like a bunch of different
you know you had a bunch of different
stuff you got your hands on everything i
think you even did i read that you were
you do uh horse racing you own
racehorses
i did i did when i got into horse racing
i jockeyed a horse for a race at
hollywood park and won the race
um went on to own 12 or 13 racehorses
including a horse that i
uh that got third place in the breeders
cup that i sold for two million dollars
that i paid 200 grand for
that's crazy to me so is owning a horse
a good good investment in general like
that's a great obviously that's a great
flip but it's it's not but i for me i
got out unscathed you know what i mean
like for a lot of people i know that are
in it it's just really for the enjoyment
of it it's a lot of fun to go watch your
horse race um
you know i had a lot of respect in the
racing community because they know i
jockey the horse they know how insane
that is right did you do that as a skit
or did you take it seriously
i know i mean i did it as a skit i mean
it's like the don't it's the scariest
thing i've ever done you're talking to a
guy who's broke the world record for
jumping a car backwards i've barrel
rolled a car i've been attacked by a
shark a tiger
it's like i've done you know broken 25
world records on a skateboard but the
scariest thing i'd ever done in my life
is jockey a horse at hollywood park
because it's just you on the back of
this horse you got a hold of its mane
you break the gate you're going 50 miles
an hour on the back of this giant beast
how do you how is your current
your your entities set up right now as
well as your focus because if you have
well i was gonna the reason i'm listing
all these crazy stuff the crazy things
that you do and all these
projects that you've got going on which
are very substantial how are you
balancing all of this and what's your
current business structure i mean do you
have like a rob deirdick media which
only does the mtv stuff and you get uh
some type of fee from them and then you
have
you know i've been i i would've let me
hey if you want to talk structure let's
talk some structure yeah basically
operate as a very
pro like a hybrid entertainment family
office right slash venture creation
studio right so i have a single entity
the direct machine llc that owns
everything including rob dyrdek inc
which is the the entertainment side of
rob deardex business so all of that
capital flows into this single llc and
then
i distribute that capital into
uh real estate holdings right the cash
flowing real estate holdings or i
distribute it into ventures that i
co-find and create right so i co-find
and create almost every single company
that i build and i i do i co-find it
with common shares and then i do the
initial funding
uh usually in the 800 to a million and a
half a million dollar
uh sort of pre-money and then i put 250
to 500 into every venture i try to own
between 25 and 70 of every single
venture that i have at maturity
um i have built 17 companies sold six
for and netted 450 million since i
launched the company in 2016. one of
those is the production company but all
of these entities sit under the umbrella
of the venture side of the direct
machine business
including rob dyrdek the television
business so
my production company that was acquired
my earn out goes into the llc
um that i own 100 of right and then
uh my talent money lives in that same
same thing then i pay myself a salary
that goes through that and then i invest
all of that
in in basically non-correlated cash
flowing
uh real estate investments whether
that's manufactured housing multi-family
units storage units like i've been
investing a lot of rv parks lately dude
this is music to my ears
yeah it's just very sophisticated
it's a very sophisticated you know
hybrid family office that i built for
myself right now and keep in mind every
venture that i create
has a has a time structure we call it
the unified theory we at the very
beginning we lay out the entire capital
path and growth path and and when we
want to sell it how much we want to sell
it for and that's our target
everything is built to sell from the
very beginning whether that's pig out
chips and outstanding foods or mind
right bars or lusso
comfort wear or any of the build builds
that i've done over the last five years
but all of it is connected
to this idea of uh the capital that
you've earned the tax efficiencies on
how you earn it and then ultimately
the irr on every dollar wherever it goes
inside the system and what do you do
then you keep your expenses within the
range of your
dividends that come from your real
estate so you basically play the entire
game for free and then as you scale and
have big exits and big big uh liquidity
events you just pump more money into the
overall system and you basically live
this extraordinary free life now
to that point i do all of this with 30
of my time right because i i manage i've
mastered time energy and capacity right
so i live this extraordinarily balanced
life by design where i only dedicate 30
percent of my time to podcasts in my
shooting television
and uh building my businesses i spend 30
percent sleeping 10 percent on my health
never compromised it than 30 with my
family you know how much is 30
for you like how many hours are you
looking at 30 of a 40 hour work week or
thirty percent of your weight he's
saying my entire life
all hours eight hours
right
no all life of the 24 hours in a day i
sleep 30 so seven hours right like i
work seven hours i'm with my family
seven hours and
uh i spend
uh three hours on my health on average
right when you look at the the overall
balance and then i could show you this
because i track it every day and it
pumps all of it into this beautiful
dashboard because what i've done over
time because to give you an idea i shot
250 episodes of television this year
it's exactly four percent of my total
time that's how highly optimized it's
become right because you basically have
a certain level of human capacity and in
order to scale it you either hire or
automate it so i live this deeply
automated life
uh that that hires people in to add
capacity and at the end of the day i
just live super balanced and happy
that's it so give us one example wait
what software are you using to track all
that time yeah that dashboard
i created i i had a i had a
programmer write me a script that goes
inside google the google calendar it's
an app on your phone or it's just on
like a spreadsheet basically it's inside
google calendar and then it pops it
populates a google spreadsheet right and
then the beauty of it is is i
qualitative data and quantitative
data is what i live my life off of right
so every day for the last five years i
asked i wrote down how i feel about my
life work and health 0-10
and so i could show you by the
qualitative numbers how i'm living a
higher quality and happier life and and
the result of that is based off the
optimization that i've done on my
quantitative stuff my quantitative stuff
is did i get up before five did i brain
train did i get in the gym did i
meditate did i have a clean diet did i
not drink i could show you by my
quantitative numbers that i have done
all of those almost every single day of
this entire year about 87
of those quantitative things that have
just driven those qualitative numbers
how i feel about my life my work and my
health
higher and higher so by the numbers i
could tell you what a high quality life
that i'm living compared to just five
years ago
you're saying somebody amazing things i
gotta yeah i've been to each one all
right so you just said something did i
brain train what's that mean
i use a luminosity app right like where
it's just adding flexibility and just
letting your mind do all of these things
that are different than just getting in
and reading your emails and you know
just going through your rhythm is really
what i i do that for and when you wake
up at five what's the morning routine
like sounds like you're pretty yeah look
i i'll get up i i i get i have to get up
before five but depending on what time i
go to bed i'll get up um
at four or four thirty two right and
then
to me uh you know always have that that
coffee pre-made so i can get up and get
cooking
um
and then i track all my numbers from the
previous day fill in all my time if i
missed any time to make sure that that
all my data is there on your phone or on
your computer on the computer right and
then
and then i try to just like organize and
knock out
sort of my more executional work before
the kids get up and all that
um then at six o'clock i brain train 6
30 i meditate
uh when i jump out of meditation i sent
we're actually at 5 15 i bring my wife a
coffee and i send her an email of every
single thing that i'm doing that day
what it means to me with a love quote on
top right
um again this is
what it means to me like each thing
you're doing just like you know just
like what you're doing you know yeah in
my in my one of the one of the pulls of
our relationship was like i do so much
stuff that she would be it'd be i'd just
be talking to someone to be the first
time she ever heard of it and so she
would just like i would do so much stuff
in a day she just would would feel
disconnected
so i just started giving her an email
every day of like what i'm doing what it
means with a nice love quote right and
and that then settled down the energy of
feeling disconnected from everything
that i'm doing um bring her a coffee at
5 15. god bless her she started doing 5
30 calls for her business um which means
she's going to be tired earlier that
means we can go to bed by 9 30 right
which is another sort of blessing
and this is happening in l.a right
you're this is yours yeah yeah and then
but you know i pop out of meditation at
seven
wake the kids up uh get them both down
to breakfast at 7 30 my trainer doctor
comes to the house
uh 7 30 to 8 30 um training and then
take the kids to school at 8 30 right
and then the day depending on what the
week is you know sometimes i go to
breakfast dates with my wife sometimes
it's you know on mondays you know i
basically run a flat organization right
so i have you know 10 core divisions
that are ran by
an executive and i just spend monday
fully organizing from when i get up four
o'clock into my chief of staff for an
hour into my president ceo for an hour
and then half hours for every single
person that runs that
uh division so that we can just be
highly organized and then plan the rest
of the week which of course is inside
thursday night date nights and friday
night sushi night with my wife and
picking my kids up and all of you know i
design balance and then i only work
within the structure of balance and then
depending on how i feel depending on how
my wife feels then i'll even adjust that
to lean into making sure that my family
is feeling
priority above business always you you
you are like yeah you're you're like you
know like people make fun of silicon
valley people because they're like like
here's my calendar i've got it adjusted
like this this and this but uh i'm
sitting here looking at you i think it
looks like you're wearing a black blazer
with a black sweater and you got these
slick air pods in you are more silicon
valley techie in tune with this than
like the stereotypes of it and i i love
it i think this is yeah i mean look i'm
i am human optimization and optimized to
to be what though to just be happy you
know what i mean like at the end of the
day that's why you're playing the game
and you got to figure out yourself
to understand what truly makes you happy
because your goal is to not be happy in
pockets
your goal is to be happy every single
hour of every single day of your life
right and that's really what i've
accomplished and i'll tell you something
if you think about how you live right
you you can live in two places that'll
get you nowhere it's dwelling and being
negative right or it's being hopeful and
like wishing
right either of get you nowhere but real
where life is lived is you're either
problem solving you're either creating
the future or you're experiencing the
present right and the truth is whatever
you're experiencing the present is based
off of the decisions you've made in the
past and it's your choice to create
whatever you your reality is that you're
going to eventually experience or god
forbid something hits you rather than
dwelling on it or hoping it didn't
happen if you problem solve and handle
it
you're not going to you can basically
live a life with no negative thoughts if
you learn to live in a state of either
experiencing creating or problem solving
in your entire life right but it's on
you to understand what that is to be
able to live in that state i'm
flabbergasted sean
rob is is just here's what i'm shocked
me
here's what i'm wondering we share a lot
of philosophies by the way the things
you're saying there's a lot of
philosophies i i live by sam lives by as
well but
i'm wondering this
in my life because i live by a similar
philosophy i've encountered a bunch of
people and what i've found maybe i'm
wrong here with you but what i found is
kind of two two groups there's a group
of people who kind of were this way from
day one they were sort of like
optimizers from day one they really
cared about they sort of recognized the
importance of time early on they
recognized the importance of their mood
and how they're feeling early on and
they say cool i'm going to design
systems to make this work for me by
default so i'm not swinging from highs
to lows
i'm not pissing away time i'm actually
making imaging so some people get it
early i don't know if that's nature or
nurture but they they were this way from
day one
and then there's other people who sort
of live life in the exact opposite way
for a while
and then it comes sort of screeching to
a halt and they say i gotta make a
change i gotta get some order and some
organization i gotta like
i gotta actually take control of this
and not just have it be so loosey-goosey
and i'm looking at you and i'm thinking
is he skater early how does the skater
guy become
human optimization
embodied the way you are were you always
this way or was this i lived a certain
way and then i had a realization in a
moment where i decided to kind of shift
my path so that i could
design my life a little bit differently
yeah i was not this way you're talking
to a guy getting attacked by sharks
who's starting company after company
breaking world records jumping cars
doing cartoons television shows doing
doing all these things as you related to
in the beginning
like you you were pulling into i would
say you were pulling energy from like
who i used to be and what you know me as
right so just as i said like
yeah right so so the way that you were
viewing was in fact really how i was
kind of living where i was being i
always refer to myself as going in so
many directions that at once i was i was
like pulled tight and so what happened
you swing from side to side in order for
there to be some sort of give and
whatever you were ultimately doing and
for me i was i
had had built my league my professional
skateboarding league and took it to
market to raise capital and and these
groups were like oh we want to we want a
piece of everything that you do look at
all that you do they offered me a 360
deal i thought this is it you know i've
just you know done this whole thing by
the seat of my pants and like finally
like these people are gonna recognize me
and turn me into the billionaire i'm
meant to be
and when they did the diligence on how i
ran my finances how i ran my life all
aspects of it they were like you're not
even investible you're just like you
spend all the money that you have like
you're not creating any value like all
this stuff and it was this this deep
awakening
of like you're not who you think you are
like you you've attached yourself this
this identity that you've created for
yourself is actually false and the
success that you've had by being so
driven and so ambitious
like as you know despite all these other
things you're doing that are failing
you're making up for it by other things
working
like it you aren't actually what you
think you are and i went on this journey
to begin the discovery
of like how can i begin to put a system
around myself to become first it was
like how do i learn business i don't
know business and i hired a consultant
to teach me how to build a company
beginning to end
and and in that process i found this
book called start at the end that was a
business book about decide what you want
out of a business before you ever
started and then it was like this sort
of like like you know insane sort of
moment that where i was like man like i
need to start treating my life like that
what life do i want and hold on
that would have been in 2013.
you know what i mean so it wasn't you
got to understand i
this
the evolution and the growth that i have
gone through over the last six years is
is four or five lifetimes of growth you
know you're talking about from from
saying you're uninvestible to creating
generational wealth
in a five-year period okay more and
and now transitioning beyond you know
self-preservation to generational
preservation what is my 500-year plan
how am i gonna affect your dex for the
next 500 years and i couldn't even in
you know i was single partying and like
part of like when i looked at like
what's my ideal life i want to have
balance and love in marriage and kids
and these things so i had to begin to
change the way that i was living to
ultimately create the energy to attract
um
the person the people the knowledge
everything that i would need to grow
into
the person that i that i had designed
for myself in 2014 and 15. and was the
you said your production company was
acquired um
was that the biggest win for you
financially
well you know i mean there's no doubt
you know what i mean but you got to
understand like even you know
it's it's such a significant amount of
capital
um and i own 70 of it right so it's just
a it's a much it's a it's a big
acquisition
um you know you know the final
numbers aren't we're still in the middle
of the earn out but it's it's oh it'll
it could be close to you know
you know 125 130 million for just me now
right and so that that unto itself is a
really significant
single transaction
um that is that very few people ever
experience you know what i mean so again
it's a in it to me it's the first
company that i built that was in the
built to sell structure right of when i
just taught myself business completely
built a system for how i would create
businesses it was the very first one
that i built to sell and built it and
sold it in three years right
and went first to the investment bankers
said i'm going to build a production and
sell it the people that only sell uh
production companies they're like okay
here's how you got to do it if you want
to build it and sell it then i went and
hired a person who just went through a
build and acquisition who was the number
two at the company to help me build it
then i went out and began to build it
now what happened a whole lot of magical
[__] happened you know what i mean like
because like
like all of these different things like
occurred that allowed me to go from zero
revenue to 50 million in the first year
that allowed like the trajectory of the
growth and the the ebitda and the
company to scale based off of
ridiculousness having a second
resurgence and me being able to
negotiate the value of the company based
off of now understanding the production
the unit economics of what the network
would need these unpredictable things
that that in the beginning but i said it
where i would build it and sell it in
three years and then took it to market
went back to those bankers three years
later here's the numbers let's take it
out and see if uh see who would be
interested now as fate would have it the
group that acquired it was the same
group that offered me the 360 deal that
said i had no value
um in 2013.
and when they acquired it part of the
acquisition i made them also acquire my
professional skateboarding league as
part of the roll-up that they created
right so it was a very poetic justice
and beautiful sort of 360 moment
as it relates to they
as the single sort of private equity
group that drove me to like re-evaluate
and really
push myself to like design my life and
then they come around and also provide
the opportunity that sets me up for the
future instead of owning half of me for
the rest of my life they acquired the
only two assets i kept
from that era
and
you don't know this rob but sam is kind
of a nut like you uh
he i think at the age of he showed me
the spreadsheet and he's like i made
this i think he's 23 24 maybe and
basically what he did was he said okay i
want to have
i forgot what it was i want to be a
millionaire self-made i said i wanted to
make i wanted to make 20 million dollars
by the age of 30. by the age of 30. i
want to have 20 million by the age of
30. liquid cash that i actually uh you
know i own liquid liquid net worth and
so he then created a list of all the
rich people he could find in tech
because we're in the tech world right
and he's like okay from jack dorsey who
created twitter and square to like
whoever
and he mapped out how many years did it
take them to make their first like their
first nut of like a million bucks and
then like how long how long before they
got their big win he's like he's like
okay the median time of seven years um
the average person is getting this uh i
need to be on this trajectory at this
and so he's like mapping it all out so i
was like i need my business to be at
this revenue with this ebitda inside
four years because that means the growth
rate is this and then if i own this
percentage that means i'm going to make
this after tax so long as i'm in this
state
yeah
everything and then it you know when did
you do it
yeah he did it he pulled it off he just
sold 31. i sold the car who was 31.
you're late yeah good for you man and
you want to know why you did it because
you started at the end
and then you know you know hey hey and
you know hey
like it wasn't about how the path
actually went you could have never
predicted you're like whoa i would have
never expected it to be in this one
whatever it may be but your mentality
was there
on what it is and you're very young
because you got to think the way i'm
talking i didn't do this till i was 40.
10 years from now for you guys you know
what i'm saying
but go ahead so i didn't mean to cut you
off i just wanted to know the payout
no you had it you know you had a point
for me on that or no i just i just
jammed you yeah
no no you're good uh the other things i
was gonna say is that we uh you know one
of the first messages sam ever sent me i
met the guy you know kind of in passing
and then you know two days later on
facebook he's like so how much do you
pay yourself out of your company and he
started talking money in a way that most
people don't most people are very
afraid to talk money and i thought at
first i was taking it back i was like
who the hell is this guy and then i was
like actually it's pretty powerful if i
could have some friends like this where
we could openly share what are we making
how you know what what did we sell for
what are we investing it in sharing
how what are we spending and it is
spending that much money each month
actually making you happy yeah that sort
of thing and so wow
this is amazing
here go ahead and so we got to know each
other that way created a friend group
that way do you have like a set of peers
like that in your world where
you kind of learned the game together
you came up together
no and but let me tell you what uh who i
do have as a peer group that i think
you'll find fascinating
have you ever heard of tiger21
yes we've we've broke down that business
a ton i actually think that you can
build a new tiger 21 because it's pretty
old school it's like all old rich guys
right
so like it's how you look
yo so i'll tell you what my tiger 21
experience is right so um to me it's not
about the business model of tiger 21 it
was about the peer group
and so this is what you do in tiger
tiger21 so in my group you know they've
really expanded it since they took on
private equity and they're really trying
to grow it so it's probably a little bit
different whenever whenever you had
looked at it in my group there's 15
people of varying ages right really
young guys that have made hundreds of
millions really young guys that have a
billion couple billion dollars in net
worth right really interesting group of
of guys
now this is what you do in tiger 21
you
each month one person has to show all of
their assets
and it's called portfolio defense right
so each person has to like lay out this
is every single thing that i'm doing so
what are we doing as a group not only do
we understand each other's philosophies
what they're spending their life
philosophies all these things but
understanding seeing how they manage
their wealth
their wealth not not not making money
but managing wealth right all all of the
latest things through their own advisors
that we share and all this stuff but at
the core of it
it's the realest of the real because you
have to be very real in order to open up
and show everybody what you actually
have and to me when i first heard about
i'm like oh my god this is the group for
me
like this is what i need like i know
that only like the realest people would
be willing to share all of their their
their investment strategies and all of
their assets and so for me i actually
have been in it now for two years and it
was
life-changing for me
right because part of that very first
portfolio defense it was like what was
your hundred year plan and it was like
in an instant i've i shifted from
present self-preservation to
generational preservation right but of
course i had created enough wealth to be
in that mindset to that point right and
now over these last couple years it is
just
it is a a depth of knowledge of wealth
building that i've
like that's so personal that that i've
just never experienced on
that i could never experience through
just people that were my friends that
weren't like open to this being part of
the structure of a club if you will
so you know look i would even say for it
for for you know you guys to even
consider it you know what i mean just
because it is a an extraordinarily
eye-opening
and you just learn and learn and learn
because at the end of the day
you're you're you grow like this right
you your your entire life as you grow
and evolve you you you expand and what
you want to do is be expanding in one
direction because that's where
exponential growth and greatness and
mastery and all these things lie when
you grow into a single direction so you
know i i
think that that it's something like that
as a peer group has been massive for me
that i didn't have before that because i
just don't i don't have anybody that
that because i come from a sort of a
different world i just didn't have any
relationships with people that that were
thinking like that were you doing i know
that you i mean you've been famous for
forever it seems and you've always been
doing cool [__] but you mentioned
earlier that when you're going through
due diligence that the the the buyers
were like dude you're running you're
like you're spending too much money or
you're maybe you're you're buying things
incorrectly and you're not you know
you're mixing personal and work maybe i
don't know but were you
were you
making a significant income leading up
to your big exit and also
i mean judging just off purely off tv so
who knows if it's real where you it
seems like you spend a lot and you like
to and you and you like to ball out and
you like to do fun stuff were you
spending a significant amount and so
like were you actually financially
successful prior to the
the the deal
and you're saying when they offered me
the 360 deal
uh when they win
like like you you sold your production
company recently although that's still
kind of mid mid
it's not entirely done right but prior
to like your well you said you read the
book in 2013 or or whenever it was were
you actually doing well or was it like
you're still getting by but you're
you're you're you're making doubt i was
not crushing it
i was making a significant amount of
income
right the the problem was i was spending
so much and not managing it properly not
not looking at what i was doing it i
would like you know i put two million
dollars
four million cash to buy the
distribution company i put 2 million
into
building the first ever street dream
skateboard movie i put 2 million into
building my league i was just making
millions and investing and building any
any which way but loose on top of having
you know a five million dollar a year
overhead and bodies in my and running
the fantasy factory and then all the
people that that were underneath me as
as part of the management team so
fantasy factory cost 5 million a year to
maintain and run like like having the
building itself was like you know 750
right and now you you put all the bodies
in there you know what i'm saying i had
you know president ceo of like
like full-time like general counsel like
ceos like i had like you know a
30-person team i was like running like
an agency almost the way that it was
built in that era you know what i mean
but also let me give you are you making
on any profit at all or or was it
breaking even and you're just spending
it i was like i was i was breaking even
because yeah i was i was making profit
and paying taxes but after taxes i
wasn't saving any money i kept reading
and reinvesting in new projects and
bigger ideas because i thought
that's how you do it
you know what i mean you just keep
taking shots and my back then i used to
say uh like our money's fearless scared
money doesn't make money and it's like
you want to know uh dumb money doesn't
make money you know what i mean like
that's like the reality of how i was
running and again it was because i was
still
i revolutionized skateboarding and built
street league skateboarding i launched
and built a cartoon on nickelodeon i had
multiple shows on mtv i i owned my
integration right so i was doing chevy
deals and microsoft deals and making
millions of dollars so i was having
extraordinary success
only
like i wasn't the way i was reinvesting
in it i was still
um essentially making rather than
creating value i was
i was really almost like a creative
services agent just kind of sloppy just
you weren't tight
was not not only not tight but didn't
wasn't wasn't creating value with
intention wasn't looking at markets and
market sizes and and trends and how
could i create a business that could be
acquired one day i'd never even heard of
a venture i didn't know what an
investment banker was in 2013 i thought
it was someone that dealt with high net
worth individuals
when i when they told me my league was
worth 30 million dollars and we did 7
million in revenue i said how
they're like oh it trades at like you
know four to five times revenue and i'm
like how
the how does business even how does that
work i that's how little i knew about
business
in
2013 when when the 360 deal was offered
to me i had i knew nothing of the
capital markets capital staging
private equity venture didn't know
anything of the first time i'd ever even
heard about it and and compared to who i
am today
and how i look at creating value and
managing capital staging and treating
myself like a family office
not that many years later it's an
exponential amount of like unprecedented
growth you know that almost doesn't even
seem real you're like transferring
through universes you know what i mean
you uh
you've been you know pretty phenomenally
successful i'm very impressed by the way
but i almost feel like you were too
early i feel like if you were 12 years
old now
because you didn't have
you know tick tock and youtube where you
you would have been
the you know the
the elk boys you would have been bigger
than the paul brothers
right like because you didn't have
social media when you were doing all
these stunts you you did it in tv you
you know you did it before tv and then
on tv but it kind of helped them in a
way right like
yeah i bet i think you would have gone
viral like nobody's business i think you
know
for the amount of views that they get i
bet mtv pays more than you of course of
course of course it's he monetized as
well but i think
fame wise if you were
a teen today with the tools they have
and you had this same kind of gunslinger
mentality of like doing stunts to
attract attention attract viewers and
challenge yourself and have fun have a
blast in public that model works today
with people who i feel like
have done like a fraction of the level
of stunts that you've done
uh do you think you're you're early i
don't know no look i'll tell you what it
makes me tired just even
having you say that it's just like god
think about being on youtube you know
what i'm saying
and like look if i even when i look at
the world right forget about sort of
being early or whatever it is like an
extraordinary exist i've lived an
extraordinary life a handful of
lifetimes but i've never been happier
than i am today talking to you because
at the end of the day there was so much
like like angst and ambition and like i
want to do something so big and i just
kept trying and trying and my will to
execute and my ambition and drive
kept just breaking me down
highs and lows highs and lows highs and
lows where now i am just in this like
perpetual str state
of like high growth in a clear direction
right and and inside that is complete
happiness right and not saying that i
didn't enjoy what i i went through but
it was too much highs and lows and chaos
and for for for what it's worth right
like it's and it's all experience and i
really love my life way more at 47 than
i did at 27 or 37 right i and that's
really what your
human mission is right at the end of the
day you want to live this peaceful happy
effortless
like fulfilling life that's really what
you're chasing right you want a a a life
of infinite abundance and love right and
and the only way you can actually get to
that is through learning mastery of self
and that is mastery of your energy and
all the things that give and take from
it your time and ultimately your
capacity right and and the only way you
can master all those is to really learn
yourself at a high level what you really
love to do and the difference is back
then i was i had to do so many things
that i didn't enjoy to feed that beast
right and and continue to find the next
thing and constantly struggling with
like i gotta do another show and it's
gotta be bigger you know it's like it's
like that sort of thing where now
everything so much more controlled and
done with purpose inside balance that
you just enjoy every moment of the
process right
um but yeah could could
i have done that on youtube no because i
also had you know an 800 000 budget that
allowed me to like you know go and do a
deal that could you know rent out uh
you know six flags so that i could flip
a car ramp to ramp over the world's
biggest skateboard that i designed
for a while
that's how much that stunt cost it was
oh no i'll shoot i don't that stunt
probably cost like altogether all of
those or a few million dollars you know
that's crazy that's like stunt teams and
groups and like test cars and like i
mean i was like
you know then then the day comes and
what do you got to do you got to flip a
car
and you want to know what you want to
know what happens on the day that you
got to flip a car you're like this is
the dumbest idea ever why am i even here
i have so much going on in my life like
why would i even put myself in this
position to like flip this car and then
you flip the car and it actually works
and now it's a super bowl commercial and
it's part of the the season premiere of
season five is a fantasy factory and
this giant chevy partnership and you
made millions of dollars and now you're
a legend and and you're gonna all this
stuff
it was genius and the best idea but the
day of when you gotta do it it's like
cool this is so dumb you know what i
mean that's basically all of those uh
all the stunts that i did in that era it
would always be like this is the worst
idea it's not even funny and then when
it was over i'd be like i'm
earlier you said that you track trends
now and you and you start at the end and
you work backwards what trends interest
you at the moment what uh what business
opportunities are intriguing to you if
you had a little bit more like even if
you aren't going to do it but you wish
you had more time and it's just kind of
on the side and you're like this is this
this interests me i think someone should
pounce on this opportunity maybe i will
maybe i won't but i'm interested
um
for clarity purposes here now now i have
a business that builds businesses right
so i i build
uh you know five to six businesses a
year right and although i've i've you
know i've kind of like really pushed
into all the builds i'm doing at the end
of the year here are all in the beauty
beauty industry uh adaptogenic um
topicals
uh water filter system saw real
opportunity and and sort of um in the
beauty space of like how important like
water is and how how many chemicals
there are and when you shower but then
you go and spend all this money on your
hair
and makeup and
skin care but you wash yourself and
chlorine
so found a real opportunity to develop a
a real innovative sort of shower
purification system and and
water filter system for beauty
um
and you know really looking at
superfoods and plant-based um
sustainable beauty products there's a
big opportunity in in
in that sort of space you know we
launched a nootropic
footwear or nootropic um
an adaptogen
uh plant-based
bar and drink mix and coffee mix line
this year that's been really successful
we looked at you know the the three
billion dollars in market share between
uggs uh crocs and birkenstocks and
created what we consider the more
the the sleeker ugly ugly shoe the
pretty ugly shoe uh and luso cloud that
we launched this year that's their last
year that that really has ridden this
wave of sort of uh comfort this comfort
wave and casual wave in the comfort
footwear world that we think is going to
be
uh on track to do really
be really big too for because to me at
the end of the day
like what's happening in a market is
important
um and it's it's going to be where you
live and die right you're too early or
you know in the case of ultra cast you
know i launched this company that was a
a a live 360
um
live 360 and vr video platform uh that
put 360 videos all over the world and
where you could jump on your phone and
travel all over the world and be in
different bars and
clubs and all these different things
like right on the conversions of live
instagram and and live content and live
streaming and sort of vr coming in
together and then what happened to vr
like
just died nothing right and it's like i
was like and what did it end up being
like the new 3d tv right and so 360
video became like the new like the 3d tv
right and so even though i built i got
it right on the wave and like it was
super innovative with an amazing ceo who
once the company went out of business
built and took a company public in like
nine months but i'm
um that that fails right so you're
trying to time markets and look at
trends and all of that but at the end of
the day
like you got to get a little bit lucky
so you want to be in the right place
white space and an opportunity that's an
investable
um there's so many nuance to a white
space and where opportunity is i can
tell you uh from someone that's built 17
companies in the last five years that
the the greatest lesson i had in years
two and three
uh was founder market fit you know what
i mean like where it's like when the the
the the biggest red flag you will ever
hear is when somebody comes from
uh you know one industry and wants to be
in another because this one's so much
easier right this one's it's the margins
over here it's the shelf stability over
here it's though there's not sizes like
they all have a position based off of
how hard their particular industry's
sort of structure is
and they're all hard they're all hard
and you don't want to invest build
companies with people that have to learn
the industry as they go right and i
think that's that's i would get caught
seeing great opportunities and ideas and
build with really relentless well
uh experienced founders
uh who get crushed in the learning curve
of trying to learn and understand a new
industry it's something that i've really
it's very hard for me to build a company
with somebody um that's getting into a
an industry for the very first time
rob we've we've had like billionaires on
we typically don't do do guests we
typically just sean and i but we've had
billionaires we've had you know gary
vaynerchuk was on recently he was he was
really fascinating we've had some famous
people we've had all types of people on
here
you might be the most interesting that
we've ever had um
you're definitely the most surprising
you know and i hopefully this isn't you
don't take this the wrong way but i i
judged you based off of just as a
skateboarding fan and what i knew about
you on tv obviously i knew you were the
slick ass businessman and you always had
some cool [__] going on but you are way
more dialed in than i ever would have
imagined and you might be one of the
most interesting people i've ever spoken
to and uh
yeah i i i think you're my new hero yeah
i i this this has been amazing
look i i i could tell by the questions
you asked me
um that that it was coming from that
sort of lens and i thought to myself man
let me let me feed this guy kind of the
uh the angle and the evolution of where
i'm operating at right you've evolved a
[__]
and think about it too it's
extraordinarily concise and clear right
because it's like i constantly am
seeking clarity so i'm always operating
from a place of intention and then i'm
i'm considering myself to have an
evolutionary mindset where it's like how
how can i purposely keep evolving and
evolving and evolving with purpose in a
singular direction and one of those is
like literally human optimization and
being happy as could be you know what i
mean at the end of the day but no i
thank you
and i appreciate it because you guys
also had me do work right you guys said
hey can you write an agenda of what you
want to talk about on today's show i'm
like these guys are like having me write
an agenda to be a guest on their show
and i wrote out an agenda and we never
even covered any of the subjects
can you come back
we didn't cover it because
you blew our mind early on
i could have took the first three things
you said and said okay i have two hours
here where all i need to do
is just let you expand on that because
if i'm listening to this and somebody
says something interesting there's
nothing more annoying in the world than
the guests going back to their pre
pre-set agenda and not asking about the
really interesting thing the guy just
said and so we had to do it uh you know
look it goes back to what you said about
building towards the end yes we had you
plan just like i planned my exit but
like what you said was you don't really
know what's gonna happen in between
yeah yeah and look even with all this
this this planning and structure
i'm i don't let it i'm not controlled by
that calendar you know what i'm saying
like i still allow myself to like but
the beauty of the system is i could just
shut down three days and everything
continues to move and it picks back
right up when i get there you know even
as i operate my life i with the same
group that helped me develop my system
for the deardeck machine in my my
business creation system
like i had them develop my life system
right and i have this this 50 page
document called the rhythm of existence
that's managed by my two assistants and
my chief of staff and it's basically the
operating system for my entire life
right and so that that allows all
aspects whether it's from my food to my
haircuts to
to like how i deal with birthdays and
how i deal with all these different
things is put into this system that's
managed that does what it's automated
and gives me back more capacity to be
able to do more be more present with my
wife and kids be more present
when i'm working be more focused be able
to get more done
because i keep adding more and more
automation and optimization to my life
that allows me to just live and do the
things i love to do which then gives me
more energy to be more successful more
clear have more intention
and push things further and further
along
would you be willing to come on again
and and talk more about like pretty much
everything you've discussed and also the
things that we've planned because this
is this is gonna be a home run
yeah look you know what i'd like to do
i'd probably like to like send you
all of my i'll send you all the stuff
that i do so you could read it and see
it and have that okay here's a live
conversation of how rob lives and runs
his life optimization then sends you all
of my business stuff including my
machine method and how i i run my
businesses through
a discovery diligence build um
uh
scale launch and scale phase and my
seven core capabilities of business and
brand product
uh media marketing sounds like you have
a new product coming out this is the the
deer deck ada program no it's not it's
just so i can build businesses
efficiently and consistently you know
this morning i told my uh you know my
head of media i said look i think i'm
going to come up with a drake equation
for business and are you guys familiar
with the drake equation
you know the drake equation is
essentially the probability of
intelligent life inside the universe
right and to me i do believe that
there's an equation that i'm i can put
through market through founder
experience founder age like all these
different things that add up to a
probability number on this company that
i'm about to create with this person's
potential successes and it's because
i've pointed
my mastery towards i want to master
curating
individuals and ideas and building them
into sustainable profitable acquirable
businesses and i just get better and
better at every single one that i build
because that mastery is going in a
single direction so my depth of
knowledge in building companies is
getting so wide which in turn is doing
what it's making me more intuitive i can
have a five-minute conversation with a
potential founder and fill all their
holes know that they're a a more
operated minded like product person like
not a brand person doesn't understand
marketing doesn't understand media oh
it's a financial mind uh that
understands product oh it's a brand mind
and product person that doesn't
understand operations or marketing or
finances for sure like you become you're
driving yourself if you want to save
energy you become extraordinarily
intuitive right like that's where your
mastery
shows itself so i digress
where i would we we could we could do a
live show and a business show
you know i'm into it
they're very similar dude this is so
good i'm so thankful that you came on
thank you so much um we're going to do
this again i hope hopefully you'll do it
but we're into it yeah yeah it's been
our pleasure thank you so much for
coming on okay
all the best now cool
[Music]
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i
travel never looking back